long before he brought Deadpool to Life
For the First Time Ryan Reynolds made
his Marvel movie debut in 2004's blade
Trinity in the role of Hannibal King he
stands beside blade himself played by
Wesley Snipes though they work together
Hannibal and blade are far from friends
which seems Samira Reynold's real life
strange relationship with Snipes when
asked by Premiere magazine if he'd ever
worked with Snipes again on a potential
blade four Reynolds made it clear with a
slight laugh and a shake of his head
that he has no interest taking into
account what Reynolds has said about his
experience working with Snipes on blade
Trinity it's no surprise that he doesn't
want to work with the actor again
Reynolds were called to IGN my
personality is the polar opposite of
Wesley I never met Wesley I only met
blade and he is a method actor he added
that he respects Snipes for his method
approach to the character and his
commitment to the craft but he could
tell that his co-star couldn't stand him
he continued there's a moment in the
movie where I look up at Jessica Biel
and I swear to God I didn't even know
the cameras were rolling anymore and I
say he hates me doesn't he